all right that was pretty fun
this is what i deal with
good morning good morning good morning
it's great to stay up late good morning
good morning
to you we are off to walt disney world
again
it is before 8 o'clock we got ready
quickly
oh my voice we got ready quickly
we are going to pirates of the caribbean
hayden has his special
pirates shirt on pebble
we're gonna have fun today hopefully no
rain and
uh last day at the magic kingdom very
exciting okay
here we are magic kingdom
okay we're on the uh people mover thing
to get us to the
park it's cold today so we're like 15
minutes later than we were the other day
and the lineups now are ridiculous
this is just to get in so nina's gonna
run with hayden to go to
the aladdin carpet rides will i run to
go get nina
a coffee no no it's okay i'm gonna get a
coffee i got nina's coffee
right here and i gotta go find them i
can't go too fast because last time i
ran and i spilled it all over myself and
this stuff is hot
and it's already spilling a little bit
there
good thing about just getting the coffee
is that you don't have to wait in line
for the barista to make it they just
bring it right to you so hopefully
nina and hayden are having a good time
and i'll be able to find them quickly
here we go
okay coming up on aladdin's carpets now
let's find it hey
nina oh there's nina there's hayden
was that fun
okay let's keep going then all right
next up is the jungle cruise
you're scared yeah
we're going on a big roller coaster
mountain thunder mountain how did you
know
right here we are big thunder mountain
railroad
what do you think mister was that fun
yeah again
next up is splash mountain
we're probably gonna get wet let's see
how it goes okay
here we go are you ready hayden you
excited
here we go oh not yet
just kidding
hold it on everything
oh no just kidding again that was
the big one jesus i'm quite my arm is
going to fall off
clutching is so tight although they're
just kidding
it's all common friendly and then we're
gonna go off the side of a mountain
how do you know who these characters are
now they're doing a big climb
this is it get ready
that was the real one
holy cow oh i gotta adjust that part
right there
wow how's hayden's hair you want to do a
check
looks good looks good we're off to have
more fun
look at nina this is what we were just
on
hey hayden shut up what did you give
nina
a flower yeah ah
very cute next up is the country bear
jamboree
you ready to jam with the bears hayden's
in this peanut butter sandwich how is it
yummy
okay let's go i want ice cream real ice
cream okay later we'll get ice cream
what is that is that singing is that
dancing
she's funny what does nina think about
it
that was a strange piggy back next up
tom sawyer island
okay let's get on this little boat to
take us over to tom sawyer's island
that's pretty rocky that bridge huh no
you did that [ __ ] purposes
me yeah no no it wasn't me hayden was a
sneak and went around the other side
he's running away let's see where he
went
whoa boo okay
you want to show us some magic powers
let's see hayden was running on the
island and he fell and hurt himself and
we just had the fire department come to
heal him up
so we got band-aids on his knee
and the other knee and his elbow
yeah and he's still hurting so we're
gonna go we're gonna go get some ice
cream
get some ice cream and be happy how are
you feeling hayden better
no you ready to have some lunch you
wanna pause it i got you something
special
you've got a special grilled cheese
sandwich that looks like a fish
and grapes and carrots and apple juice
and nina has a chicken salad and i have
a burger
and we got a coke okay you want to stay
in there do you want me to pick you up
and put you on the seat
no okay you can hold it here here
get your grilled cheese and apple juice
okay
okay yummy for some reason a french fry
disappears from my plate i don't know
what happens
let's see if we can catch the thief oh
that's your finger
there's mr hayden he's the one stealing
my french fries
nina had one tiny bite of a hot pepper
which is freaking out no 1
3 one third of a hot pepper
did you steal hayden's grape
wait are you stealing my french fry wait
a minute i'm going to steal a piece of
corn
all right what did i steal
a tomato okay how you feeling hayden
better thumbs up
oh wait does that mean we don't need to
get ice cream anymore
we need to get ice cream do we still
need to get some
yeah yeah okay let's go get some for you
okay thank you
here you go maybe nina can open it
great oh we need some napkins for sure
we need napkins because hayden's going
to make a mess where are you okay
is it mine zach you have my wallet
my turn for something yummy i got a
pineapple twist in a cup i usually go
for the orange
but they move the orange stand i didn't
want to walk all the way over there so
we're going pineapples
let's give nina the first bite
what are we gonna watch next what are we
doing
are we watching the mickey show yeah
so because you got injured they gave you
some free passes some fast passes so
where are we going to go what do you
want to do
we'll get the key later but what else do
you want i want to go on
buzz lightyear okay and
okay now we're gonna take the train and
go back
to the main park the entrance and see if
hayden still wants to get his
key okay we're on the train well we're
almost done for the day
and then we're gonna get my dude yeah
we're gonna get your key
before we came we made a deal that
hayden would get
one thing he would get the pick one
president instead of saying i want this
i want this i want this i want this and
driving everybody crazy
he get one present it's day three
and he said he had he had to like the
same thing for two days in a row
it's now day three and he's wanted the
same thing
for the third day two full days in a row
and it's this
key is that a yes
you're not going to ask for anything
else you're not going to ask for
anything else
yeah are you going to shake on that
shake
okay and why do you like the key tell us
because
hold it up and let's see looks like
the power of everything okay all right
we're back in the car
i'm tired how are you feeling i'm okay
nina's okay how's hayden feeling fine
i'm the only one who's tired all right
well i'm tired uh oh yeah this was a
stressful day
hayden hurting himself how are you
feeling now better better you got your
key
so uh we gotta go pick up a um what do
we
buy sd card because i'm i'm making like
13 gigs of video a day with this camera
and i'm running out of space on my
laptop so i gotta do an sd card
then home relax shower
dinner league of legends goodbye magic
kingdom
it's the end of our day here hayden's
gonna go to bed
tomorrow is uh was supposed to be our
shopping day
but it's uh supposed to rain like crazy
on friday which was
our magic our animal kingdom day
so we are going to make tomorrow our
animal kingdom day
and go shopping on friday so we get
stuck in the ring good night everybody
see you tomorrow
good night good night baby
self-improvement books are like fitness
books they never work on their own
what you need is a trainer that's evan
get the newsletter